alrededor de una vez al mes o cubre un
conjunto de eventos conocido como el
ciclo menstrual que prepara el cuerpo de
una mujer para el embarazo los cambios
de los niveles de sustancias químicas
naturales en el flujo sanguíneo las
hormonas controlan estos eventos los
órganos reproductores afectados por
estas hormonas incluyen la vagina
el cuello uterino
el útero
las trompas de falopio
y los ovarios los ovarios producen dos
hormonas principales llamadas estrógeno
y progesterona a medida que el nivel de
estrógeno comienza a aumentar hace que
la mucosidad del interior del cuello
uterino que normalmente es espesa se
vuelva más líquida el estrógeno también
activa a otras hormonas para provocar
que uno de los ovarios libere un óvulo
este proceso se llama ovulación
si una mujer tiene relaciones sexuales
durante este periodo las células
reproductivas del hombre llamadas
espermatozoides pueden atravesar la
mucosa más delgada y fecundar un óvulo
en el útero el estrógeno hace que el
endometrio se vuelva más grueso
preparándolo para recibir un óvulo
fecundado el aumento de los niveles de
progesterona hace que las glándulas del
endometrio liberen un líquido que
alimenta al óvulo fecundado
la progesterona también hace que la
mucosidad del cuello uterino que se
había puesto más líquida se vuelva a
hacer más tensa para impedir el paso de
los espermatozoides
si el óvulo no ha sido fecundado los
niveles de estrógeno y progesterona
comienzan a disminuir
esta disminución de los niveles de
hormonas provoca la menstruación un
proceso en el que el útero expulsa por
la vagina sangre y el tejido que recubre
el interior del útero
un implante de progestina es un método
anticonceptivo
previene el embarazo hasta por tres años
el dispositivo se implanta debajo de la
piel en el antebrazo de la mujer un
implante de progestina es una varilla de
plástico flexible que tiene el tamaño de
un fósforo y contiene una hormona
similar a la progesterona llamada
progestina
está diseñado para ser visible en las
radiografías
el implante libera continuamente
progestina en el cuerpo los niveles
altos de progestina ayudan a evitar que
el cuerpo libere otras hormonas que
causan la ovulación
[Música]
sin ovulación no hay óvulo disponible
para la fecundación por lo que la mujer
no puede quedar embarazada
una segunda manera en que la progestina
evita el embarazo se relaciona con su
efecto sobre la mucosidad del cuello
uterino los niveles altos de progestina
mantiene la mucosa del cuello uterino lo
suficientemente gruesa como para que el
esperma no pueda atravesarla una tercera
forma en que la progestina evita el
embarazo es a través de su influencia en
el recubrimiento uterino a diferencia de
la progesterona natural la progestina
tiene una composición química
ligeramente diferente con el tiempo hace
que el recubrimiento uterino sea más
delgado en lugar de más grueso como
resultado si se llegara a producir la
fecundación de un óvulo el endometrio
puede ser demasiado delgado como para
permitir su permanencia en el útero por
lo que se produce la expulsión fuera del
cuerpo en el siguiente periodo menstrual
un médico puede insertar un implante de
progestina durante una visita al
consultorio para ello el médico hace dos
marcas con un marcador estéril
una para el sitio de inserción y otra
que utiliza como guía para la dirección
durante la inserción
posteriormente el área de inserción se
limpia con un antiséptico y se adormece
con un anestésico local
a continuación el médico utiliza un
aplicador especial para pensar la piel
con una aguja hueca que contiene el
implante y deslizarlo debajo de la piel
finalmente retira la aguja dejando el
implante dentro
después de colocar el implante el médico
se asegura de que la ubicación sea
correcta palpando ambos extremos del
implante debajo de la piel se aplica un
vendaje sobre el lugar de la inserción
el sangrado menstrual con un implante de
progestina puede incluir cambios en la
frecuencia del sangrado la intensidad
del sangrado y la duración de cada
periodo de sangrado aunque es posible
retirarlo antes el implante se debe
quitar después de los tres años
el médico puede reemplazarlo por un
implante nuevo en ese momento si hay
sospecha de embarazo es importante que
la mujer consulte con su médico es
posible que sea necesario retirar el
implante
un implante de progestina tiene más del
99% de eficacia en la prevención del
embarazo esto significa que menos de una
de cada 100 mujeres que utilizan este
método anticonceptivo quedan embarazadas
por año para obtener más información
sobre cualquier tipo de método
anticonceptivo hable con su médico